butchers expected to testify later today
in the trial of an alleged serial killer
called the Hollywood Ripper Los Angeles
prosecutors say that Michael Gargiulo
attacked three women killing two of them
including Ashley Ellen who was friends
with the actor 48 hours correspondent
Maury Mar has been covering this story
for more than a decade now and she's
outside the California Superior Court in
Los Angeles so Maureen what do we expect
Ashton to say today so Gill Ashland will
be called by the prostate the
prosecution in order to establish time
of death of one of those LA area victims
Ashton Kutcher was scheduled to go on a
date with a with Ashley eller in on the
morning on the night that that she was
murdered at the same time he couldn't
get her on the phone earlier in the
evening so he goes over to her Hollywood
home and then knocks on the door mr.
Kutcher is part of the chronology of
this case during opening statements
prosecutors told jurors they believe
Ashley Ellen was attacked from behind by
Michael Gargiulo after she exited her
shower on February 21st 2001 it was
around 10:45 p.m. when Ashton Kutcher
arrived to take her to a Grammys party
mr. Kutcher looked in the window and saw
what he thought was spilled wine on the
floor we believe now the evidence will
show that was actually blood Kutcher
allegedly told police when she didn't
answer the door he left
Elle Arun was found by her roommate the
next morning brutally stabbed to death
prosecutors described Gargiulo as a
methodical systematic killer
he's accused of attacking at least four
women three in California and one in
Illinois Michelle Murphy the
prosecution's first witness was
allegedly Gargiulo the only survivor
prosecutors claimed Murphy battled for
the knife they say Gargiulo used to stab
her cutting him and leaving his DNA at
the crime scene
DNA that was found years earlier on
another victim across the country why
were you all called to be here they are
using our some of our case with these
California
cases due to the the link of the DNA the
family of eighteen-year-old trisha
Picacho was called to testify in this
trial because of the similarities
between Trish's 1993 death in suburban
Chicago and the three cases from LA
County investigators believe Boccaccio
was Gargiulo s-- first victim her murder
remained unsolved until 2011 when two
witnesses came forward after watching a
48 hours mystery report on the case
within a few weeks gardulla was indicted
but has not yet been tried his attorneys
say he is not guilty of killing anyone
the Picacho family had never met the two
witnesses who blew open the case until
they all came to LA to testify I think
was very noble of what he did he rose
right yes but the picaros must wait for
the trial here in LA to end before
Gargiulo can be brought back to stand
trial for their daughter's death
fighting for this case goes on with me
forever and that's the way it's gonna be
I have said through several days of the
testimony here all of which has been
gut-wrenching and gruesome but ashton
kutcher the witness who seems to have
garnered the most amount of attention is
only expected to be on the stand for a
few minutes Barbara Thank You marine
thank you very much your murmuring along
to this one you this is joy watching it
for a long time you know Ashton really
plays it seems a very small role in this
case he's the name in the case but I
keep thinking about the victim's family
you just want justice that's the most
important yeah that's right